Sie jagen meist in der Dämmerung oder
nachts, lautlos und im Rudel:
Wölfe in Deutschland.
300 Tiere soll es geben allein in
Brandenburg rund um Berlin –
Tendenz steigend.
Auch die Bauern merken immer deutlicher,
dass der Wolf zurück ist.
Die Rudel jagen neben Wildtieren auch
ihr Vieh auf den Weiden.
Der wirtschaftliche Schaden ist hoch.
Für den Brandenburger Landwirt
Jürgen Frenzel
werden die Verluste durch den
Wolf längst zur Existenzfrage.
Die Wölfe werden meiner Meinung
nach geschickter.
Wir haben den Eindruck, dass sie
ringehen in die Herde,
die Herde jagen, und bei diesem Jagen
separieren sie ein Kalb.
40 Kälber habe er 2017 verloren,
zehnmal so viel wie im Jahr zuvor.
Entschädigung gibt es nur,
wenn der Wolf als Täter eindeutig
nachgewiesen wird.
Schwierig, wenn Kälber spurlos verschwinden
oder eine Kuh ein Junges durch
den Stress tot zu Welt bringt.
Mit Zäunen sollen die Bauern selbst
für Schutz sorgen,
doch die Investitionen dafür sind hoch.
Wenn wir für unsere zwei Herden
mit insgesamt 180 Tieren
den Zaun so wolfsgerecht bauen wollen,
müssen wir knapp
100.000 Euro investieren.
Und wir bekommen neuneinhalbtausend
Euro ersetzt dafür.
Auf die Verluste der Bauern hat
Brandenburg nun reagiert.
Es gibt die Wölfe zum Abschuss frei,
wenn sie trotz aller Schutzmaßnahmen
so wie bei Jürgen Frenzel
mehrfach Vieh eines Bauern reißen
oder gar einen Menschen angreifen.
Dem Wolf auf der Spur sind
auch Naturschützer.
Stefan Hoika verfolgt seit Jahren
die Entwicklung eines Rudels
in seiner Gegend und ist überzeugt:
So dramatisch ist die
Situation gar nicht.
Und wenn der Wolf nicht durch
Futter gelockt werde,
meide er auch den Menschen.
Sie sehen ’ne frische Wolfsfährte,
die ist von letzter Nacht,
wenige Stunden alt.
Und mir ist es in neun Jahren fünf-,
sechsmal passiert,
dass ich mal einen sehen durfte.
Aber in der Regel sind die so scheu.
Sie beobachten uns,
das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Hoika sieht sein Rudel meist nur
durch die Fotofallen,
mit denen er die Wölfe beobachtet.
Da dreht er sich um, weil er die Kamera
auslösen hat hören.
Den Blitz kann er nicht sehen,
das ist ’n Schwarzblitz,
halt sehr vorsichtig.
Die Tiere müssten ihren Platz in Brandenburg
haben, sagt der Naturschützer.
Wölfe mit Behördenerlaubnis zu schießen,
das sei noch gar nicht nötig
und Panikmache.
’ne artgeschützte Tierart,
die streng unter Schutz steht.
Und bei den paar Wölfen,
die wir hier haben ...
Man muss nicht immer alles
hochmultiplizieren,
was hätte, wäre, wenn,
wenn wir 30 Prozent Zuwachsraten
haben im Jahr.
Ich kann das alles nicht mehr hören.
Wir haben’s noch nicht,
wir haben noch nicht mal 1.000 Stück
in Deutschland.
Nicht mal 1.000 Wölfe –
den meisten Jägern ist das noch zu viel.
Der Brandenburger Jagdverband
fordert strengere Regeln.
Das große Raubtier passe
nicht in die moderne Kulturlandschaft.
Nötig seien feste Abschussquoten.
Und die Jäger wollen freier entscheiden,
wann ein Tier geschossen werden muss.
Einigen würde sogar nur ein einziges
Rudel in einem deutschen Reservat reichen.
Ein Rudel sind vier bis sechs Tiere,
und die können da nachhaltig leben.
Die können da ihre Jungen großziehen,
die können da haushalten.
Und dann,
ich denke, ist das ’ne gute Sache
und dürfte eigentlich auch allen
gerecht werden.
Und wer dann mehr Wölfe sehen will,
der soll in den Zoo gehen.
Positionen, die unvereinbar sind mit den
Wünschen der Tierschützer.
Im Streit zwischen Jägern, Bauern und
Naturschutzverbänden
droht eine wirksame Strategie
für eine künftige Wolfspopulation
auf der Strecke zu bleiben.
Wir müssen weiter daran arbeiten,
bis es besser wird.
Alle miteinander?
Auf jeden Fall. Also, wenn ich sehe,
wie ich hier mit der Jägerschaft
zusammenarbeiten kann,
ist das ein Vorzeigeprojekt,
so was habe ich noch nicht erlebt.
Meistens trifft man nur auf Widerstand:
„Scheiß Wölfe, knallt die alle ab.“
Kann ich nur mit dem Kopf schütteln.
Vor 100 Jahren wurden die
Wölfe in Deutschland vertrieben.
Die Tiere in Natur und Landschaft nun
wieder zu integrieren,
trotz der dazugehörenden Schäden –
diese Aufgabe kann nur der Mensch leisten.